you've been praying diligently but
something seems blocking your prayers
let's break down the barriers today
but before we do that let's pray Father
in heaven we thank you
for the invitation to come to you the
god of the universe and pray
we know that your ears are bent low to
hear the petitions of your earthborn
children
so today as we study about prayer give
us wisdom and may we be drawn closer to
you in Christ's name amen
Our Hope lives 365 Media Center is
centered here in the Living Hope Seventh
Adventist Church
we built our church about six years ago
while we were when we were building it
one day just before our grand opening
the inspector was making the final
inspection
he came to the church
and talked to me and he said you know
Pastor Mark you're not going to be able
to open in a few days I was absolutely
shocked because we had sent the
invitations out people were flying in
from different parts of the country it
was going to be a great day of praise
and celebration for what God had done I
said well sir what is the problem he
said a car hit a light pole out in front
of your church and that light pole is
actually on your property it's a unique
light pole that matches the other light
poles in the shopping center where your
church is located at the end of that
shopping center
and until you can find a light pole like
that and repair that light you cannot
open
I was concerned deeply concerned
and went home and began to pray and I
prayed dear Lord this is going to be a
miracle I have no idea where that light
pole is none whatsoever but Lord you
know
we need to find that light bulb light
bulb
and as I was praying the Lord impressed
me you don't know the factory that made
it but why don't you call the manager of
the shopping center and ask her
I had developed a relationship with this
manager cordial friendly relationship as
we were building the church so I gave
her a call
and she's I said look we've got a real
problem we can't open until we find this
light pole and we put it up two
manufacturers said to you know she says
I don't know who manufacture it but I
know this
we have one store in the shopping center
we haven't rented yet and in that store
we are storing different things that we
may need later she said I was in that
shop the other day
where we're storing these things and
there was the exact light pole you need
lying on the floor
of the store and I thought how can we
get rid of this we don't want it Pastor
Mark here's the combination to get into
that store because we got a lock on it a
combination lock go and get the light
pole put it up within 10 minutes I was
there got our construction people within
an hour we had that light pull up
how did
I know to call that woman God impressed
me through his holy spirit
God does answer prayer in Psalm 34 verse
17 this is what we read about God and
the prayers of the righteous
Psalm 34 17 the righteous cry out and
the Lord hears and delivers them out of
all their troubles so God longs to
answer our prayers but you say Pastor
Mark
what hinders my prayers at times at
times I pray and it seems that there are
no answers at times I prayed it seems my
prayers go up to the ceiling come back
down now there are four things that may
hinder our prayers number one if we
Harbor sin in our life known sin we all
fail we all fall short of God's glory we
all make mistakes but there's a
difference in harboring sin there's a
difference in
committing Rebellion against God when we
know what we ought to do Psalm 66 Verse
18 says if I regard iniquity in my heart
the Lord will not hear now notice it
doesn't say if I sit as if I regard
iniquity in my heart in other words if
my heart is in Rebellion against God if
I willingly knowingly live a life out of
harmony with God's will that blocks
God's answer to my prayers why
the only prayer that God would answer
for a person who's in active Rebellion
is a prayer of confession a prayer of
repentance but if God would shower his
richest blessings upon us when we are
regarding iniquity in our heart living
in known sin he would justify that sin
in fact in the Book of Proverbs
chapter 28 verse 9 you have a very
similar Bible passage to the one we've
just read in Psalm 66 Proverbs 28 verse
9. one who turns away his ear from
hearing the law even his prayer shall be
an abomination in other words if I live
a life of knowing willing Rebellion
against God God cannot answer so the
first reason some of our prayers are not
answered is because there is known sin
in our life so unanswered prayers lead
us to reflect
they lead us to meditate they lead us to
open our hearts to the Holy Spirit
asking the Holy Spirit to convict us of
any known sin in our life that's
blocking our prayers now the second
reason some prayers are not answered is
because when we pray we pray selfish
prayers to Simply gratify our selfish
desires you say Mark is there a pastor
Marcus there are Bible text on that
there is James chapter 4
remember the Book of James right after
the book of Hebrews and James the fourth
chapter and the Bible puts it this way
it says
James 4 verse 2 you lust and do not have
you murder and covet and cannot obtain
you fight in war yet you do not have
because you do not ask you ask and do
not receive because it says you ask and
do not receive that you're praying
you're not received why
because you ask amiss that you may spend
it on your pleasures in other words if
the motive in my prayer is simply to
gratify my own selfish desires and
pleasures
God does not hear reminds me of a story
I heard about a little girl
she was five years old now her prayer
can be justified although she didn't get
an answer because she's five
she's one day kneeling by her bed and
praying and her father passes by the
room the little girl's praying like this
dear Lord I want as a pet a pink
elephant Lord you know I want a pink
elephant more than anything else Lord
please send me a pink elephant after she
stopped praying her father came down
into her room and sat on the edge of her
bed she was all tucked in holding her
teddy bear getting ready to go to sleep
and daddy looked at he said honey I
heard you praying for a pink elephant oh
yes Daddy I was asking Jesus or a pink
elephant uh honey
um
where are we going to keep that pig
elephant Pink Elephant Oh Daddy you can
build a barn in the backyard for it we
can keep it there uh who's gonna feed
the Pink Elephant they eat a lot of food
Oh Daddy you can feed it every morning
who's gonna pay for the food Oh Daddy
you you can pay for it then he thought I
got this one
you know pink elephants make a lot of
doo-doo honey
big pile tattoo who's gonna clean it up
Oh Daddy you could do that too do you
think God ever answered her prayers for
Pink Elephant you say bathroom Mark of
course not but if you prayed for Pink
Elephants things that you wanted when
we're praying one of the things we want
to do is align our prayers with God's
will you remember in John chapter 8
verse 29 Jesus in his prayer said I do
always those things that please him
and in Psalm 37 it says delight yourself
in the Lord and He will give you the
desires of your heart if i Delight
myself in the Lord my desires become his
desires so when I'm praying I don't
force or superimpose my will upon God's
will that hinders my prayers when I'm
praying I say God is this your will God
I only want to do to want to do things
that please you so two reasons our
prayers are hindered and two solutions
one there's no sin in our life the
solution is meditation seeing if and
asking the Holy Spirit to convict us if
there is something in our life blocking
our prayers second is we pray selfish
prayers and those selfish prayers
block God's will so the answer to that
is saying God what do you want God all I
want is is your will the third is
faithless prayers so the first is
prayers with sinful nature sins in our
life the second issue is selfish prayers
the third is faithless prayers you
remember the story of Jesus who comes
down from the Mount of transfiguration
his disciples are they are trying to
cast demons out of a
child the father has brought the child
the child's writhing in pain and
suffering and his eyes are rolling in
his head he's foaming at the mouth and
the disciples have no power to cast out
the demon Jesus comes down and casts the
demon out and Jesus tells them
in Matthew chapter 17
exactly what happens in Matthew 17 Jesus
tells them why they couldn't cast out
that demon Matthew 17 and verse 20. so
Jesus said to them because of your
unbelief for surely I say to you if you
have faith this Mustard Seed you'll say
to this mountain move and from here to
there and it will move nothing will be
impossible to you
was Jesus indicating that if you had
enough Faith you could move Mount
Rushmore Mount Whitney not at all what
he was saying is the mountains of
difficulties will move the mountains of
problems will move the mountains of
challenges will move if you have enough
faith
Dwight Moody tells the story of
traveling from England to a speaking
appointment in Canada
and the captain came and said to the
passengers the
boat is fogged in we are not going to be
able to land make land in a sufficient
time as we had planned we're going to be
many hours late Moody knew he would miss
his appointment so he said to the
captain let's go down into the hold and
pray the captain was a supposed
Christian Moody prayed a simple prayer
dear Lord I've never been on an
appointment that I haven't asked you
ahead of time if it's your will you
revealed to me this was your will and so
Lord all I want to know is Lord your
power Your Grace reveal yourself to us
and clear this fog
as he finished praying he said Lord by
faith I know you'll do it because I'm on
your assignment
the captain was going to pray Moody
tapped him on the shoulder he said
Captain you don't need to pray for two
reasons one God already answered my
prayer and two you don't believe he'll
answer yours
they get up and went upstairs and soon
gradually the fog began to lift and
Moody made his appointment
When you pray if you do not believe that
God is going to answer your prayers that
is a hindrance
now there's a fourth reason why our
prayers are not apparently answered
and that is
timing we pray but it's not God's time
you remember the story in the Book of
Daniel
where Daniel prays for three weeks for
Cyrus to sign the decree that the
Israelites could go free from me to
Persian bondage
Babylon had fallen the 70-year Captivity
was about up and as it's about up
Daniel's praying he prays for three
weeks there is no apparent answer to his
prayers at the end of three weeks Jesus
comes to him he Daniel faints at the
glory of Christ then an angel comes
likely the angel Gabriel comes to
explain to Daniel what has been going on
and Daniel chapter 10 verse 12 then he
said to me that's the angel do not fear
Daniel for from the first day that you
set your heart to understand and to
humble yourself before your God your
words were heard and have come because
of your words so from the first day
Daniel Prayed his prayers were heard but
Daniel didn't see that there was a
timing issue as Daniel Prayed that Cyrus
would have light in his mind and that
the
uh decree would be signed the evil
angels are bringing Darkness into
Cyrus's mind they were they were wanting
Cyrus not to let Israel Go free and
there was this battle between good and
evil for we've wrestle not against flesh
and blood but against principalities and
powers and evil places Ephesians 6 10 to
12. and So eventually eventually Jesus
comes down and the evil angel spread
flee Cyrus signs the decree but if you
were Daniel you'd have thought and if
you didn't have faith
you'd have thought your prayers are
going up to the ceiling and bouncing
back but they weren't God was working
out the solution so there are three
things to remember here that God is
teaching us when there are no apparent
answers to our prayers
he wants to teach us patience he wants
to teach us perseverance and he also
longs to teach us
the
praise to praise him when our prayers
are not being answered knowing that he
will answer so if our person not being
answered what do we do we examine our
heart to see if there's any sin in our
life
secondly if our prayers are not being
answered we ask am I praying a selfish
prayer thirdly if our prayers are not
being answered we say to to ourselves
Lord
I
want only your will my loving heavenly
father and all I want to do is what you
want me to do and I'm going to pray in
faith believing that you will answer
and then if our prayers are not being
answered we have patience we persevere
we praise God knowing
that from the first time we prayed
God hears and God in his own time in his
own way is working out a solution trust
him trust him and trust him some more he
loves you he will answer your prayers
you've understood why God might delay or
deny an answer but have you ever
wondered if praying for others really
makes a difference if you want to know
the answer watch this video next